cannot got to see I'm loving some kind
of demon on the scale kind of lead and
room in this van so you take that ah
with James Bond ever in prison I don't
know
yeah yeah maybe maybe me all right no I
think of myself as kind of getting to do
a little bit of an action role in this
all right something I haven't done
before in order to prepare for that role
I I watched all of Bruce Willis's movies
and when that didn't work I just went to
his hairdresser as you know and because
your vase I'm imagining that this job
was a proper dream come true for ya my
job is I'm sorry because this is like
fun okay I'm a big kid and I can't
believe my luck and I've been a fan the
muffins 30 years I store watching
Sundays with my family and them so yeah
this was this is a good call to get and
I I didn't know this guy before
no you let that is it's my my best pals
this is right yes yeah we are brothers
you don't give me your email address
right yeah keep asking for it money they
look a bit I'll be supposed to stay in
touch will not give me your email
address there's a debate I think about
him a lot and I say to my girlfriend I
wonder where Constantine hi I'm Connor
I'm Constantine what does it feel like
for everyone to hate you wow I don't
hate you Nikki you want to feel the eyes
I see my question
- bad guy ah question there is possibly
this kind of enjoy being the bad guy and
enjoy being hated you know I was written
that way
so what can I say Lady Gaga do a song
about that oh yes I was written that way
yes I uh I have to say though it may I
say Connor we don't hate him
well it's it's sort of just the story of
the movie you know he's actually old pal
from the swamp
I think he's his best friend now me
either did yeah he's a good guy in the
movie easy little bug yes I think I
think doing this movie and meet in these
sort of thought his little heart of
stone you see he was born in a pond in
Russia but I ended mothers and sisters a
trip without poles my niece is through
many of them I fish right yeah um um
what you know showing him love has made
it a cuddly little thing tell me how did
you want to give the microphones the
minds the next year wait I thought
you're just passing out microphones to
everyone like a they give ya a goodie
bag yes we're sing-along again hi guys
fantastic film hurry I can't concentrate
everyone yesterday um Ricky how did it
feel it's a bit of a controversial
question potentially being upstaged by
current constant I know doesn't happen I
know I knew from day one that you know
it's because the first thing that the
word me in the script was a song and
dance number um okay a singing you know
on the cloud pop star I always sneak a
song and I wrote songs with David Brent
still doing it oh well some would they
bury for extras I wrote a song in Sesame
Street without Mo Simpson's dancing
little bit awkward and then I think oh
my god do this in the road sorry it's
gonna be a frog on-screen dancing
they're not going to really be care what
you are doing with your clumsy little
short legs and that so I thought it was
sort of meant to be awkward as well um I
I love being upstaged by these things I
ruined a lot of takes just I love them
just I just I just really I just once I
went
I'm in the Muppets I'm cut
yes you are with the Muppets listings
again yeah that's a typo I can't believe
my luck
I'm good kids constant time are you
worried about being us he worried about
being typecast well you know the one
thing that I am really worried about is
authorities catching up with me and also
my face being placed up everywhere so I
feel like a new change career paths
maybe maybe I will be an agent in
Hollywood huh yes hmm
perfect son good yeah you can do that
yeah anyone can done wrong don't throw
the mic um I've got a question for
Kermit and Constantine what do you think
about the fact that these days the word
Muppet is used in a pejorative or
derogatory fashion amongst us human
beings what's it like as Muppets with a
big M to hear us humans say oh you
Muppet and hear it sounds a use we're
like it we're sort of like a rep company
you know I mean I'm not I'm not a
species called Muppet I'm a park you
know I belong to a group called The
Muppets and I quite frankly I see the
point um you know nervous yeah total
swamp I think is this super affection as
well you call someone a pit down there
when they made an error whether yeah
just everywhere we all make mistakes
especially the Muppets especially when I
mix and that's Joey love you Oh HM
affection your muffin yeah yeah why
thought there are worse things to be
called yeah I'm carless it's not Ricky
Gervais and in the movie I see a journey
scam an Irish journalist specifically
get paid off to get the Muppets good
reviews do you think this that's pretty
reflective of how
I don't think so I think everything's
heightened and I was with a Irish
journalist yesterday live instead so
about the flat caps from the old cars I
did an episode of alias right that
wasn't a joke and a while ago and it was
meant to be sitting at a pub in Dublin
and all they were missing was a horse I
mean there was raw
there was me Monty United with really
smoky every it looked like a 1950's but
this is sort of heightened so yeah it's
it's playing with stereotypes if
anything but um there are horses in the
centre of Dublin oh yeah but in pubs
Hayley Hayley they run them they run the
past and kind of solid but at a price
any remains did you invoke the character
of David Brent for that that was it
there was a little boy you know I did
that back song and dance many times I
didn't complain once to them I was like
I'd live yeah the recognizes
choreographed but that business sure
Ricky knew that's what he can do exactly
get it that's my best balancing that you
might have been a little bit more
difficult to work with than the guy
Patsy he would have to say that never
say that no there is only one thing one
particular character that was really
hard to work with her so difficult to
work with I tell you everybody knows who
it is let's just get it out to the
opening
an introduction right on cue P talking
about war nothing looking opposed nice
to see you hello my person over there oh
now this is either Khedive you see did
she's not with me by the way that's not
really that's a nice hat by the way
thank you very much yeah Scott's
congratulations on a brilliant film and
piggy one thing have you here the
ultimate diva finally in the room my
question I guess is to Kermit and piggy
I'm actually getting married next week
and I wondered as one of the world's
highest profile celebrity couples if you
had any particular advice for me piggy
perhaps my beautiful soon-to-be wife and
Kermit and for me as a soon-to-be
husband I think I think I need some
advice from you and your lovely because
uh you're engaged and I'm not response
coming I advise our full compliance the
only way to go in a modern marriage huh
but are you marrying a barnyard animal
or just like a human oh good good yeah
so crisis that I noticed in the Muppet
movies when they get married and have
children
it's either a pig or a frog hmm there's
no hybrid weird abomination that's trig
test room we've got three freaks places
you can go with I like the colors yeah
yeah yeah will happen this is a question
for Ricky I would like to know what is
for you the true spirit of the Muppets
and I think trying your hardest and
optimism I think that the acceptance oh
I love that of not intentionally but
about dasai acceptance of difference
that isn't even commented on other than
a good thing you know we've the
difference and I like the fact they
struggle I've always liked the struggle
I do in comedy a lot I think it's a
sense
from Laurel & Hardy a beautiful thing
like those was the fat very precarious
they could fall any moment and I loved
the relationship so I think that and
optimism
it's nothing always supported it you
know even some of my David Brent I like
David Brent because he made a fool of
himself and then he got back up and I
think that's I think that's the spirit
of the Muppets which is lovely and then
it's fun deconstructing that for another
audience that that nice little not
cynicism but awareness of this of this
magical world your best I think videos
try your best is very important that
applies for me learning to the
characters the markets but also to our
human stars that I don't want you to be
able to sing and dance perfectly it's
about trying your best and that's really
most important to me and that's lucky
for you the real spirit of the Muppet is
flawless beauty okay
oh and that yeah of course that William
can I ask you to step yes just taking
aside our incredible cast of stars that
we have here but you have an amazing
selection of Cummings in the film as
well how how do you decide that how does
that come about is that it script stage
yeah is it it works by poisoned agree
but largely we write those roles in the
script and I've mean what the name of
this particular person and what we find
is that because it's a great love for
the Muppets people we ask tend to say
yes which is really rare I've been at
many times that other situation was
really hard so it's amazing where we
rise you know a number for Piggy mutants
that's will be her fairy godmother her
advisor spiritual advisor about love and
relationships and you think while he'll
be amazing evokes maybe Celine Dion why
that a nestling feeling and then you
phone her up and she goes yeah I've ever
done no problem of it is amazing and
never ever happens so yeah that's ready
other the selection of Russian inmates
is just the most yes ding house neat
season yes oh yeah I'm a little confused
because Rolf speaks of foo foo dozen so
because like that also quickly my wife
and I have agreed that if we have a boy
we're gonna call it Kermit but we got on
what we call girl you're not gonna pin
that on the poor boy
yeah I'm tired girls night I don't think
you want to go with piggy Bruce you're
some I oh just a pet she's hardly
sentient you know yeah well roast an old
piano playing gar yeah I don't think we
what type of film you I see the Muppets
in next you've done adventures you've
done fables you don't this is Carol's
what we see next is young you all want
to do who you asking all of us the best
genre is obviously sequel everyone knows
that
as for us we know these films get better
better with every see mmm grease the
train entering Godfather 3 sure so
waiting forward to the next Sikh or
whatever is Muppets less wanted sure why
not
why don't anything because Marcus
convert often they don't often following
sequence anyway so it could be a Jenna
thing that I just had done everything so
he knows that the sky's limit could be
anything effect I'm personally hoping
for Muppets well rested movie night
ominous that would be really good
yes yes I am I my questions to over King
James how difficult was it to work with
the beauty of Miss Piggy constant
distraction say hmm obviously she's
right next to me I know she can't reach
you as your essence yeah now you guys
know how I feel all the time I want I
want constantly to answer this I'm sorry
I was not paying attention I always have
to work with big and that constant I'm
so distracting on Adams I'm distracting
here at the press conference they can
take their eyes off of man you boys
you must pretend to love her than you in
the movie yes it was my best acting I
have now after the scene by doing this
is anything a PI's RL right now himself
a couple of your lab selling Footwear
that's what it tastes like Jason the
Ruby uh first question is - Ricky you
know you posted it on Globes you broke
lovely the actresses in Hollywood
how does piggy compared to the icons you
work with um she's a bigger diva and she
won't mind me saying that because I
think she's sort of proud of it it's a
compliment yeah - beer - Kevin big kids
either talking about herself all the
time all the time other people are
talking about me out I'll be quiet
look know all the pies do you inspire
them we have billions of people around
the world when you guys are growing up
especially common amongst the tadpoles
um who is like you guys growing up your
big idols go oh I think for me it was
probably uh um Walter Brennan
oh great American actor yeah Walter
Brennan you know nobody has a clue who
I'm talking about do they maybe James
you gonna get me try again I think for
me it won't know I was inspired by so
many people
I had great grandparents you know old
frogs old frogs are great inspirations
I'm struggling financially to help me
give me something funny well I'm not a
muppet so I can't say as a memory what
my generation that's boys there's great
safecracker named Thomas there's not a
hole in every neo Brian
there is other he is explosives expert
it is Tommy the toenail Luis oh I love
Al Pacino's I mean the godfather part is
Christian yes I can go impression of
email for a famous line for a movie I am
Al Pacino the Godfather I go outside and
then I gotta get back inside
Wow very good
don't see well not very good early I
think that's more a cappuccino than
Elvis
oh yes mom was an inspiration to
everyone of course and getting myself
sweet you know but before I go on stage
or on camera I always just look at the
mirror and then looking at the way very
quickly yeah thank you boy James as well
great cameos you also got some great
locations and I wonder if the Muppets
opened the doors of the Tower of London
in places I think they probably did
because famously you're not allowed to
film there pretty much ever and they
turned down everyone they lost but it
starts before but somehow when you have
the Muppets with you you say you ask for
the paper those people tend to change
their minds and yeah sure so we actually
were filming a talent of a good three or
four days that's amazing how does he
find so many autographs
yeah she looks he's a beautiful song
there we sell so many textures
it was very popular as amazing as a
remake experience so maybe somewhere
that someone the Crown Estate maybe some
upstairs and royal families at market
fair may pick oh I think so I glued
we've had a quite a connection with the
ones I loved those people question for
Ricky and in 2000
you had a small role and and it was
later Kosh were you disappointed when of
us coach and were you and reser prize
they asked you back
and this would be a good time for you
two to hash this out of an accident it
was ileal it wasn't it wasn't really a
roll it was me turning up as myself and
it was me and was it Christy crystal
yeah the host of the Oscars and host of
Golden Globes print thinking about it
was surfing yeah it was a it was sort of
stand-alone thing so were no no and I
James told me I agreed you know you
can't you can't put it in there just
because you filmed it you know a film
about was it four hours of it enough um
yeah no I didn't I didn't list it you
know the great thing about James is he
tells you that before you shoot the
scene we're not gonna use this with this
tomorrow
yeah everyone here we go questions for
Ricky and which one you found friendship
with Constantine have you thought about
perhaps orchestrating an Idiot Abroad
special racing car and Constantine off
oh yeah I see a lot of similarities
little round head and that's the way the
brain would be if a head didn't stop
there I do anything with constant I
would I would travel the world to its
constant a type we will not go to France
tour then all your no going rods
honestly I might host the the Oscars
with with this guy alright then let's
make it happen
great nice it is amazing what qualities
to constantly look for number two oh
this is good question
you must have evil snarl like Ricky
Gervais says you see you must have
opposable thumbs so you can move things
around and read so library card yeah
very important
yeah but the checkout books about yet
you have to check out books and you know
for evil plotting oh the life is a party
but you always make sure to return the
books yeah candle lights it I am evil
criminal I'm not you know in my
respectful - yeah you know what I got a
job for something as simple as that no
no no I'll be home we're in the
fictional world what the markets like to
work with example would you like to work
with what's a grommet person you know
it's tough it's tough to choose somebody
fictional because we're the only ones
that aren't computer-generated you see
so they're not really there you know
it's hard to work with them you can see
them at press conference if we were if
we were those people here's ready guys
here's what this press conference would
be to just be to you all right just give
away know about those friends yahzee on
the back of her head to take Europe
you're a weak pointer see chris is an
actor um I've done nightly museum I just
done three and Ben Stiller is in it a
lot and he's in the scenes where all the
animals come to life but they're not
really there so he spends six weeks
running around talking to a tennis ball
on a stick
well as you're acting you're acting with
these guys which is it's brilliant and
it's pretty fun yeah it also makes a
difference with the timing and the
realism and the I think the affection
for it it's it's real
you cannot stick your finger down tennis
balls throw true oh no you can never
host the Oscars here to know why are you
always trying to me about welcome uh
fulfills is in sexual references to all
different styles different films and for
me when I favorite films is the Pink
Panther return and time girl's character
and that whole was that really drawn
from that
what's the visit of every French person
ever yeah when you have Sammy will be
most patriotic American deputy to color
foil for that is the most European ie
Frenchie French person at Versailles him
just be as approach as possible and I
said don't worry about which region of
France you from just need the superest
French's person ever and they'll do that
and that works perfectly well and say
does a great job he's wonderful linkage
and if I can ask you to stay Stewie
thank you so much for your time can you
give a huge